wow we have a trailer to a Super Mario
Brothers movie these Super Mario but
it's phrased differently it's not Super
Mario Brothers the movie that's
something else that killed Mario movies
this is the Super Mario Brothers movie
not Super Mario Bros they swapped the V
to the front that actually does put into
perspective how much pressure is
probably on the creative team to stick
this Landing they must feel like they're
in a nightmare where they're naked on
the biggest stage in history all eyes
are on them they're like if we botched
this we just kind of kill Mario movies
for another three decades
I empathize that is pressure we're all
rooting for him really and the scope and
tone of this world you see in the
trailer it feels like Mario it feels
like the Mushroom Kingdom the Mushroom
Kingdom feels vast expansive it feels
like a world you could spend well an
entire game exploring it's like Mushroom
Kingdom if Mushroom Kingdom had the
scope of breath of the wild it's kind of
what it reminded me of Bowser looks like
Bowser Mario looks like Mario in fact I
like that I like when Mario hopped on
screen he didn't look like some original
Sonic trailer hybrid Mario monstrosity
or something generally looks like Mario
and that goes for the voices as well
when I heard Chris Pratt was Mario I was
like
is it gonna sound like Chris Pratt and
Jack Black was Bowser I was like is he
gonna sound like Jack Black you hear the
voices in there but I was impressed how
much Jack Black is doing a Bowser Voice
open the gates and Chris Pratt's even
kind of doing a Mario voice and although
Chris Pratt sounds more like Mario than
I thought he would it is still the
tougher pill to swallow Mushroom Kingdom
Here we come because he doesn't sound
like Mario from the games because like I
said one of the most iconic characters
of all time there was a time when the
data I don't know if it was data or
Internet chatter but the conversation
was Mario surpassed Mickey Mouse as the
most recognizable mascot of all time and
we've known the voice of the great
Charles martinet as the voice of Mario
thank you very much for playing my games
for decades so yeah Chris Pratt's voice
as Mario sounds weird to me but there
was a time if we're going back in time
I'm old enough to remember a time when
the definitive Mario voice as we know
Mario now sounded weird Mario sounded
like this hey Paisanos it's the Super
Mario Brothers Super Show then Mario 64
comes out and it's all like it's me
Mario and I was like that sounds weird
but now collectively we all accept that
voice as Mario but that's kind of that's
how when things are different it freaks
us out so as Chris Pratt sounds like
Mario cosplay right now I imagine by the
end of the movie it'll be fine but I do
hope he knows the job he took on do you
think it was just like hey Mario and
he's like great I love those games let's
do it or was he like one of the most
recognizable mascots on Earth with one
of the most recognizable voices I
let me get back to you can I have a few
days to think about that but in the end
this trailer for The Super Mario
Brothers movie I was impressed by it it
feels like the Mushroom Kingdom Bowser
feels like Bowser Mario feels like
mario-ish oh we got Luigi Luigi getting
some love because it's like at a point
Luigi just kind of got left by the
wayside it was like yeah Super Mario
Brothers Super Mario brother or singular
so my hope in this movie is that Luigi
actually does something important
something where it's like they wouldn't
have won without Luigi doing what he did
you know make it truly a Super Mario
Brothers needed to be there kind of
thing all right so the trailer to the
Super Mario Brothers movie have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]